it's a big idea Jordan bizdev Sundays
here we go doesn't matter like a vision
I see with clarity muscle like my name
is Gary Thomas I've been telling you
I'm triple-a having a pedigree as the
meaning on special my specialty
I'm putting the work that I'm doing are
the moving furniture to heaven
[Music]
like almost 8 o'clock at night it's been
a weird weird day not to work out Jordan
just passed the laundry room heard
people yelling guy yelled the score
can't believe the Falcons are winning 20
well nothing I tried not to know
anything about the game or watch
anything about it so my prediction is
Pats win anyway hook up this morning on
one hours sleep slept the whole flight
landed hung out a little bit I have to
take a nap just dead I just woke up what
a weird day just a weird weird day for
this workout and came up with a little
fun idea for Sunday's so I'll record
that in a minute
it's called bizdev Sundays it's a big
idea Jordan so I'm gonna do biz dev
Sundays what I'm gonna do on Sundays is
listings for you the community of things
that I'm up to that might be business
opportunities for me and you now the
thing that scares me about this and why
I don't normally do this is like a tons
of emails like hundreds that have
nothing to do with them right people are
trying to really stretch it a little
shorter one make sure here's you know
like really stretching if it could
actually can do this or whatever I'm
asking for is really a fit but hopefully
it works out so actually you know what
let's do best
dev Sunday at vaynermedia comm team
create that email this way it won't be a
horrible in this way bunch of the team
can jump into the email with me
so ready first uh the first biz dev
Sunday I don't know grab your phone but
I got it small brands to do stuff with
laughing its oh right so Vayner sports
as you guys know one of the things I'm
trying to do is change that sport a
little bit and do endorsement deals that
have never been done before
obviously the Nikes and Under Armour's
and Thetis and Reebok deals in the
panini sports cards those are all
standard deals that will work with and a
lot of that has to do with wherever the
kid is coming out of school like those
are slotted in and you negotiate them
but I want to do unique things
up-and-coming brands right like no
stripes or headbands or bees or socks or
granola bars or trail mix or you know
pomegranate juice or coconut water
before they were big is a real
opportunity for my athletes that are
gonna have a big social media profiles
become new star rookies in their cities
and big college stars you know Jalen
reeves-maybin John Toth for Kentucky and
Tennessee now you're thinking about like
if you're a regional play in the middle
America and you want to hit that fan
base of them being college stars and now
they go to the pros so these are the
things that I'm looking for so if you
are a startup brand t-shirt ramp and
you're willing to pay a small amount of
dollars to my players to be one of the
faces of your brand and put it on their
social or we create content and you put
on your social or if you want to give a
piece of the equity of the company for
those guys kind of that vitaminwater
deal that David Wright goddamn 50 cent
on biz dev small brands with my
up-and-coming athletes and so the
athletes that we're building around
banner Sports is today's Sunday first
biz dev
yeah it's Basenji now we're not all
right number two on the biz dev Sunday
list by the way this thing the hell is
that what's called a valslide okay
number two stickers and posters if
you're a company that uh and by the way
well-well put like a sticker so posters
visit that for brands so put whatever we
put down here in the title when you send
it to the email so that we don't have
any confusion and whoever's jumping in
and handling it could go through a
quicker stickers and posters stickers
and posters obviously the things that
create t-shirts and all the quotes and
the stuff on Instagram all that stuff so
many people asking for stickers and
posters I'm looking for a company or to
a startup that wants a biz dev with me
what I'm looking for is starting at free
that's the best deal for me exposure and
all the different people all the way up
to like whatever I think that this best
deal is is where we pissed at what's the
value prop what's the exchange I know
people get so sad about free if I have a
sticker poster company where I printed I
was paying somebody that had a big
audience and be willing to do it I did
it a ton with gourmet library give away
free cheese forever I did with my
baseball cards when I was fifteen that
you ate three cards to the biggest
dealers the thing because it made
relationships and they built on that but
that's a different story for a different
day what's the best deal who's got a
sticker company big shout out to sticker
meal done a bunch of stuff with you in
the past but really this is this dev
Sunday this is for me and my community
to do business together if we think we
can match and so sticker and poster
companies that are willing to print on
the man and ship
people on the other side of this camera
because one of the biggest things I want
to do with the 60-second Club which a
reaper thing but I'm gonna cook
60-second Club back on Instagram put on
your notifications I want to give away
you know a bunch of the posters and
stickers of that quote in real time and
a lot of fun so stickers and posters
number three is I just mentioned the
60-second Club is back I'm focused on it
I'm putting people on my team on it one
of the reasons I faded out create a
five-minute Club was because I was
worried that I couldn't couldn't get
into all the comments but give me a
little more time big thing is I just
want to deliver on this you know I'm a
big fan of surprising delights right
like the thing I did the other day which
Chipotle I love this stuff I call it the
Taylor Swift thing I just like I like
doing nice things that are fun for the
community like if macho man did this
back in then he had an Instagram account
I would put my notifications on and what
he would post if I click it if that gave
me a FaceTime with him or like a sign
like shirt or it would've been cool so
anyway nonetheless 60-second Club if you
don't know what it is when I post
something on Instagram if you like and
comment within the first minute you
become eligible for me or somebody on my
team now because I just needed to add
that to make sure I deliver to jump in
pick one two three random people each
time to win we leave in the comments you
DM the information my team will ship out
stuff just a little fun little thing for
the for the community and a great way to
make sure you're keeping up with those
two or three posts I'm doing every day
on Instagram 60-second Club back focused
be a part of it
get rocked on my workout here like all
happy I want to sort beanie company I
decided a brand new beating cubby not
like the Gary B's signature or not in
Gary V shop I mean just like a beanie
company so I'm looking for somebody who
is really great at sourcing high-quality
materials for production and so I'm
looking for somebody to give a little
piece of equity to to come be on my team
on this to be my partner a creative
director to design the concept got a
good idea of what I want to do but make
it better for that person to make it
better and somebody on the sourcing I'll
take here the design and marketing
website all that distribution I think I
keep it up pretty quickly but somebody
to actually produce the first 10,000 go
start a beanie company because i´ve
leared them all time and I miss retail
want to sell something so it's something
that's not like a [ __ ] face/off cool
who wants to be part of the beanie
company hit me up now do it yet perfect
not I've got hustle and I need to be a
part of this you have experience in
producing you know product that has been
sold at retail direct consumer in the
fashion space and you have a creative
director background around it as well
like oh experienced only young hustlers
we've got many millions of other things
to do with you but this one that's what
I need so don't waste your time
or mine and finally sorry I'm not gonna
bop
and finally clip it clip one clip one
minute clip it whatever we want to call
it will come with the hashtag you know
just clip it in the YouTube sections
comments your favorite one-minute clip
from everyday levy that we can then use
for an Instagram Facebook and Twitter
video so a new group of people who
follow daily me who when they watch the
episode say hashtag clip it two minutes
and 13 seconds to 3 minutes and 13
seconds we'll use the community to
decide which Clips we should be making
in our one minute Instagram Facebook and
Twitter videos who's part of the Clement
community let me know in the comments
how long may 12 64 hours carries yeah
yeah I still not strong enough stronger
one is greater than zero
worse workout ever
[Music]
yeah it's Benji now we're not check it
check it huh I said this industry is
dog-eat-dog he got sleeping on these
Mickey D's rappers around me that I've
been eating cuz I got my city y'all they
come up and they got my back
they've been loving the kidney when the
words filling the flippin ago an absurd
I kill it
the real is from Chapel Hill in a minute
when I limit you were witness to the
game but I'm only thinking winning
living in a road we battle to the top
either make it or you drop til the game
will never stop nope
so what